qu avons nous oublié
à partir de ce jour que n'est plus les
libelles ardo nous vous avons à partir
de fou pour tuer le pape sy 13
je dois d'abord boire mon coca cheer ici
par le réalisateur oscarisé paolo
sorrentino me de prêts comme ça
beauté exceptionnelle non mais
franchement qui aurait pu imaginer que
l'ennemi ne viendrait pas pouvoir
très saint père vous pêchez je n'ai
aucun péché au fait c'est qui est tu
délires
je suis une contradiction comme dieu tu
es gosnay que dalle d'une et camouflées
en culottes courtes ces mois de mai 2010
en part
la situation était déjà si problématique
pas encore mais si elle devait nous
devenir nous devons y être préparés
je vois vous le reflet du christ
ils ont hélas pas pour que tu ne savais
rien et aujourd'hui mais commence à
réaliser
voilà leur plus grand péché n'ira pas
qu'ils croyaient être comme les entends
je suis le seigneur tout puissant alors
au mignon ça
jude law diane keaton ludivine sagnier
cécile de france
nouvelle création originale payante pop
lundi 24 octobre sur canal+